dès la nuit tombée dans ce centre de
dépouillement de la capitale les
conteurs de voix se met au travail toute
la journée de dimanche
quelques six millions et demi de
burkinabés étaient appelés à voter pour
leur futur président et députés un
scrutin déroulée dans un calme relatif
dans les grosses villes mais tendue dans
les régions du nord et de l'est où les
attaques deviennent ils sont nombreuses
des bureaux de vote ont même dû fermer
sous la menace d'hommes armés alors que
d'autres n'ont même pas pu ouvrir lors
du vote d'aujourd'hui deux bureaux de
vote ont fermé dans l'est du pays près
de pâma car des rumeurs d'attac leur
sont parvenues kalt à leur a dit que si
les élections se poursuivaient ils
seraient attaqués c'est pourquoi ces
bureaux de vote ont été fermés et à
ouagadougou également deux bureaux de
vote ont été fermés
au total selon la commission électorale
autour de 300 à 350 milles personnes
n'ont pas pu voter en raison des menaces
sécuritaires
le président sortant roch marc christian
kaboré et l'ue en 2015 fait figure de
favori mais l'opposition fait monter la
pression
elles dénoncent des risques de fraudes
et menace de ne pas reconnaître les
résultats
tout cela nous interpelle c'est pour ça
que nous avons décidé depuis hier de
porter plainte auprès du procureur du
faso
mais nous connaissons bien la lenteur
d'une instruction judiciaire ce que l'on
veut ce n'est pas d'attendre deux
semaines trois semaines au plus vite est
enclenché nous on veut quelque chose on
change eh bien maintenant et ça c'est
vous ne vous trouvez votre vigilance qui
va nous aider à faire cela des
allégations réfutées par le parti
présidentiel qui affirme ne pas avoir
besoin d'une quelconque fraude pour
gagner les élections
environ dix mille six cent soixante
observateurs nationaux et internationaux
étaient déployés dans le pays afin de
s'assurer du bon déroulement du scrutin
les résultats quant à eux sont attendus
sous sept jours